hey breezy can you hear me
what's going on how are you oh i'm
really
i'm really good how are you doing i'm
doing pretty well you look lovely today
thank you we're getting i'm getting
ready to take the kids to a movie oh
okay at a movie theater
yes they're only playing older movies
we're gonna go see the original back to
the future
oh that'd be nice for them huh that's
yeah one of my favorites show them what
it was like back in the day when uh when
a man had to wear a puffy vest and still
look like a decent man you know
yes um what's been going on so you
are you guys have been during this
pandemic how's it been because you have
three children right
i have three my son just left today he's
moving to wyoming to finish his senior
year with his best friends with his dad
oh wow that's was that kind of sad or
how did you feel about it
i had a good cry
two to go and is he a decent kid is he
pretty decent
oh my kids are the best kids you have no
idea i don't know how they wound up
so good they're really really
good-hearted
amazing respectful kids who make good
decisions
i don't know what happened to them it
wasn't me wow are you sure they're kids
because that doesn't sound like kids at
all
they're they're not normal kids i'm
telling you um
so what what did you guys do during this
was it pretty rough out there for you
guys during this um
during the quarantine and all of this
kind of stuff how was it over there in
utah
it was rough work out really hard i lost
my hours
unemployment wasn't paying for a minute
i wound up joining
only fans i started my own only fans
and um since then everything's been
better we don't have everything open yet
so we're still just stuck inside but
um time's all hard for a minute but
everything's flicking up now and
it's starting to open up a little bit
yeah i mean yeah so uh
so wait so yeah obviously things yeah
things got tougher people so you open up
an only fans
like a provocateur female provocateur
kind of
environment exactly wow
okay it was i i wasn't sure at first if
it was something that i wanted to do but
it's been really successful and i made
it to the top eight percent
oh wow so yeah so this is just you
needed some you
look you got to be able to survive you
have three children um
yeah i i i support that that's i
probably won't look at it
um that's okay okay don't ask me what's
on it because you're gonna have to pay
for it if you want to know
okay uh yeah look
my imagination can probably i mean i
have no idea
i'm sure it's wonderful i think it's
really cool um that you are
figuring out ways to to make things
happen during this you know
uh yeah really really good and uh
yeah i'm just i'm kind of torn because i
know like i try not to
venture into the wild you know into the
wat into the wilds of the web
not for everybody so that's okay i i
respect that
and i respect that you have it and i
know that we can still support it
and not and and i don't have to go there
out of
you know not out of i wish i wish
everybody
thought like that what uh what is it
well
yeah what is it do you feel like sharing
that is that okay
yeah no absolutely i just i share nude
photos explicit photos and
sometimes video clips oh wow no no what
do you is there a link or something
where people
are just uh that's what i meant no no i
can guess what it is
is there a link or not i don't want to
like i'm just saying if people
look here's what i'm saying i support
the fact that
mom's got to do what mom's got to do and
look it's a tough time i love it i'm
glad that you are
finding ways to provide and if we have
listeners that even i'm not going to
tell those
young fellas to get out there and watch
it but if they want to support it
where can they support it
they can go to only fans you can search
me on instagram
on only fans and on tick tock um
under havana gypsy all the same name
on any of those three and you can find
my only fans through those other
social media havana gypsy huh
let's see that comes out here only fans
and so
and was that something that do your did
the kids know about that
my kids know about it my my they haven't
seen it but they do
well yeah they all know about it even my
youngest now knows
wow my daughter's in she's behind the
camera my my middle's here with me
yes she knows about it oh well look
that's wild i mean look i love it you
know people put their artwork out there
uh you know beauty is a form of art and
the female body is a form of
art and i love it absolutely
so what about is it is there more
pressure now that the sun is gone like
who's gonna step up and be kind of like
the
the the next in command there at the
house
my daughter's like she knows it's her
she's
my second hand anyway before him even i
always called her to help me with
everything so um she's here with me oh
anybody this is here you know that
they're all just really good to help
they'll help me they'll hug me when i
need it they're good kids man
god i love that i wish they would have
raised me i feel like
there's still time there's still time
and i still need to be raised as well i
think um
so what uh did your family feel like get
closer over this pandemic did do you
feel like it was kind of a tough did you
feel like it didn't help
what were some things that kind of
happened as a family unit
um me and my kids or me and my siblings
yeah maybe you and your kids
the kids and i we've been i mean same
i've
been home more because part of my
my nightlife my going out you know
having friends and having things to do
and so
that's all closed down so i've been at
home you know more
um but we really we just do the same
thing we've always done you know we just
hang out at home we'll put on movies and
kind of just hang out it's what we do
but
we have been going roller skating they
opened the roller skating rink back up
so we've been doing that too
i love that god i love that
and does your daughter kind of meet men
at the roller skating rink or does she
do
dating or what's her does she do she
just had a boy
uh how old is he
18 18 year old picker up the other day
and they went to see a movie
oh my god don't tell me he was a
comedian was he a comedian i think i
know him
hey um that was her first kind of date
um and that that was fun but no she
haven't met anybody
she's had a few friends at the skating
rink but no boys and were you nervous
about her going on this date how did
that
was that kind of a fun thing what was
that like no
i wasn't nervous she had fun they just
they just hung out she
actually knew him from school he
graduated last year um so she knew him
from school so i wasn't nervous as long
as
she knows him and feels comfortable
enough to go with him she's got her
phone she can call me if
she needs anything and she knows that so
i wasn't nervous she had a good time
dang that's cool you guys are lit you
guys are like few
you guys are like this future family i
feel like in a strange way
you guys have a lot going on just it
just seems just
i don't know maybe i'm just living a
boring life but um
well hopefully whenever yeah when comedy
opens back up we'll have to
come in and check in and get to bring
you out to another show
i hope you do i would love it yeah we
certainly will
and uh yeah we're gonna send something
over to want to do something nice you
can do something fun with the kids and
um or the one less kids now but um
well look it's nice to see you and i
hope you guys have a wonderful time at
the movie
it's so good to see you hear from you
you're an awesome guy i had a lot of fun
on our singles night out
any love interests over there any love
during the pandemic for mom or what's
that like
listen i don't know i don't know
okay we'll leave it at that to be
content
there might be something just barely
starting we'll see
okay well i'm gonna keep my fingers
crossed for that um
awesome well uh thank you so much breezy
for for just checking for
checking in and chatting with us and uh
and i hope you guys have a wonderful
um whatever it is a month a day a year
everything
thank you it's good to hear from you all
right you too i'll talk to you soon
all right bye okay bye bye
wow so look
look it's the 21st century what you know
what i'm saying these ladies out there
mom's got to survive she's got three
little ones
i'ma support uh look we put our support
behind single moms
and so you can support breezy you know
and uh
and that's you know it's different times
you know mama gotta earn the bread
that's it that is it look
at least she's out there making money
too i remember my
dude i remember some a mechanic feeling
my mom up for free
so this ain't that baby those days are
over
um so maybe [ __ ] i would have nick get
us a membership but dang
me or him doesn't need any of that in
our lives really we got
and i'm not saying i don't i just i got
dude i open my eyes and i see them
you know 30 50 vaginas and titties and
booties
bhs man buttholes you know what so i got
enough of that in my head and my damn
jug right floating around
so i'm trying to log off of my own
thoughts half the time
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah